في تقدير ان الازمات لن تنتهي لان نظام
المصرفي العالمي يقوم على قاعده المتاجره
في الديون وليس في التنميه راس المال اذا
الدين
الدين يعلو على الدين والدين يعلو على
الدين والدين يعلو على الدين الى ان تصل
الى كون من الديون ويكفي ان نشير الىنا
حجم الديون على مستوى العالمي تجاوز 300
تريليون دولار 300 الف مليار دولار 300
الف مليار دولار وهو ما يعادل ثلاث مرات
حجم الاقتصاد العالمي بمعنى ان حجم الديون
على مستوى العالم يتفوق على الاقتصاد
العالمي ككل بثلاث مرات اذا لن يكون
الاختصاد العالمي ككل كافيا في ان يواجه
حجم الديون الكبيره
[موسيقى]
في ظل استمرار العمل وفق اليه السعر
الفائده كقاعده للتمويل وجد العالم نفسه
في اذار مارس امام ظاهره انهيار بنوك ذات
اسماء كبرى مثل بنك سيليكون فالي في
امريكا ودوتشي بنك احد اكبر البنوك
الالمانيه بجانب بنك كريدي سويس المتعثر
في سويسرا فمن كان يتوقع ان ينهار بنك
السيليكون فالي ما الذي حصل والى اين سيصل
وهل ستفلس بنوك جديده هل بدا النظام
المصرفي الغربي يفقد ثقه الدول الكبرى به
وما علاقه الازمه باسعار الفائده وهل
ستتاثر منطقتنا العربيه بالازمه ان روعه
اوجي وهذه حلقه جديده من بودكاست الجزيره
بعد امس نحاول خلالها فهم ازمه الافلاسات
والانهيارات البنكيه الاخيره في امريكا
واوروبا مع محرر الشؤون الاقتصاديه في
موقع الجزيره ناد الزميل محمد افزاز اهلا
وسهلا بك محمد اهلا وسهلا بك وبالمستمعين
والمشاهدين الكرام
او اخذت ودائع من المودعين باسعار فائده
متدنيه بحدود 0.5 الى واحد بالمئه خلال
فتره الركود التي تزامنت مع ازمه كورونا
للفتره 2022 كانت اموال رخيصه ماذا تعني
اموال رخيصه ان الاقتراض كان سهل بمستويات
متدنيه وحتى الودائع ايضا كانت بمستويات
متدنيه لكن عندما
ارتفعت اسعار الفائده
اصبحت هذه البنوك ملزمه بدفع تعويضات اكبر
للمودعين لان هذه الاسعار قد ارتفعت ما
الذي توجب على هذه البنوك هذه البنوك
عندما توسع الفارق ما بين اسعار الفائده
في المرحله الاولى مرحله الركود
واسعار الفائده في مرحله الانتعاش كنزاما
عليها ان توفر هذا الفارق
ماذا فعلت ذهبت راسا الى بيع محفظتها من
السندات لمواجهه هذه المطالب المتواتره من
قبل المذيعين هنا حصلت الخسارات خاصه
بالنسبه لبنك واد السيليكون او السيليكون
لكن الازمه بدات حقيقه بدات مع البنك
الاول
او يسمى بنك سيلفر الذي تاثر بانهيار منصه
رقميه عالميه والتي تاثرت ايضا بدورها
بالازمه القائمه التي ربما تاثرت بارتفاع
اسعار الفائده اذا في البدايه في ثمانيه
مارس انهار البنك الاول بعده بيومين انهار
السيليكون وبعده بثلاثه ايام بدات سلسله
من انهيارات الكبرى هنا تنبه
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي والسلطات الامريكيه
وكان لزاما على ان تتدخل بضخ اموال لانقاذ
هذا المشهد لان المشهد العام كان هو الذعر
هو هذا الذعر انتقل الى الاسواق الماليه
وتاثرت اسواق الماليه والبورصات وانخفضت
اسعار العديد من او مستويات عديد من
الاسهم في البورصات ولعله سهم والسيليكون
او السيليكون فالي ربما نهار باكثر من
سبعين بالمئه وهنا بدات الانهيارات الكبرى
طيب يعني ما علاقه الازمه باسعار الفائده
يعني مازلت لا افهم ذلك سيرني لاني لست
ضليع في الاقتصاد مثلك
كما قلت في الفتره من عام 2019 الى العام
2022 وهي مرحله ازمه كورونا المشهد العام
كان هو اقتصاد راكد تاخر الاقتصاد اصبح
راكضا كان من واجب الفطره الامريكي ان
يخفض اسعار الفائده لاتاحه اموال اضافيه
في الاسواق اضافه اموال اضافيه في الاسواق
يعني ذلك رفع من مستوى الانفاق لدى الاسر
انفقت الاسر كثيرا
وعندما ترتفع احجام الانفاق يرتفع الطلب
عندما يرتفع الطلب اوتوماتيكيا ترتفع
الاسعار لانه الطلب يتفوق عن العرض وقتها
العرض كان متاخرا لماذا لانه سلاسل امداد
العالميه
كانت مقفله بسبب كورونا بمعنى انه مثلا
الصين اكبر سوق تصدر على مستوى العالمي
كانت مقفله بسبب ازمه كورونا اذا ازمه
السلاسل الامداد جعلت المعروض من المنتجات
والخدمات اقل
في مقابل ارتفاع في حجم النفقات ماذا ادى
ذلك ادى الى ارتفاع مستويات التضخم
لمستويات عاليه
في هذه اللحظه تراكمت عند البنوك ودائع
كبيره جدا بلغت بالنسبه للسيليكون فالي
انتقلت من 60 مليار دولار الى 189 مليار
دولار ماذا سيفعل السيليكون بهذه الاموال
ليستثمرها لابد ان يستثمرها ماذا فعل جزء
منها توجه به الى الاقتراض وهذه طبيعه
البنوك لكن الجزء الاكبر بحث عن
الاستثمارات في السندات الامريكيه لانها
تعتبر سندات امنه السندات الامريكيه عاده
تكون بحدود 1.5 الى اثنين بالمئه كعائد
اذا المودعون اودعوا بسفر فاصله خمسه
بالمئه الى واحد بالمئه وهو كان لزاما
عليه ان يوظف هذه الاموال في السندات
الامريكيه بواحد فاصله خمسه الى اثنين
بالمئه حتى يكون الهامش الارباح واحد
بالمئه حتى يرجع فيعطي الاموال للمودعين
وايضا للموظفين وارباح المدراء والمسؤولين
تماما لكن بعد فتره الالفين 2022 بعد
ارتفاع اسعار
وارتفاع التضخم كان لجمع الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي وهذا دوره ان يتحول من سياسه
التيسير الكمي اي ضخ اموال اضافيه في
الاسواق الى سياسه ما يسمى بالتشديد الكمي
اي
امتصاص السيوله من الاسواق لانه من دوري
ان يخفض من الانفاق حتى يؤثر على الاسعار
في الاسواق فتعود الاسعار الى مستويات
الطبيعيه فينخفض التضخم
لانه الاحتياطي لديه في السياسه النقديه
شيئا اثنين التيسير الكمي
والتشديد الكمي التسيير الكمي هو ضخ اموال
اضافيه في الاسواق لرفع الانفاق لانعاش
الاسواق لنعود الى الانتعاش من جديد بعدما
كنا في الركود
عندما يصل مستوى انتعاش الى مستوى قياسي
يهدد الاقتصاد لانه التضخم يصل الى
مستويات عاليه يعود الاحتياطي مره اخرى
فيدرالي الى التماس سياسه الانكماش او
التشديد النقدي ماذا يعني ذلك يرفع من
اسعار الفائده
حتى يصبح الولوج الى القرود اصعب لانه انا
عندما اقترض بسعر فائده اقل يكون الولوج
الى القروض اسهل فاذا اقترض كثيرا انفق
كثيرا اطلب كثيرا ارفع الاسعار كثيرا ولكن
في النص الوقت هو عندما يرفع اسعار
الفائده يسعى يرفع ايضا اسعار الفائده على
سندات الخزينه اسعار سندات اسعار سندات
ترتفع الفائده لكن دائما السندات
الامريكيه تكون فيها ثابته العائد ثابته
العائد ولذلك تعود البنوك مره اخرى لكي
تواجه ارتفاع اسعار الفائده على الاقتراض
وعلى الايداع لانه الاسعار الفائده عند
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي هي وسيله
للتحكم في السيوله النقديه الموجوده في
الاسواق عندما نخفض اسعار الفائده يعني
ذلك ان نتيح الاموال
للمستهلكين للمقترضين للمستثمرين لانعاش
السوق
في حاله ركود نحتاج الى اموال كيف سنحصل
على الاموال من خلال اقتراض كيف سنجد عفوا
نلج الى الاقتراض لابد ان تكون اسعار
الفائده منخفضه او ما يسمى بالاسعار
الصفريه صفر بالمئه او واحد بالمئه اذا
اصبح انا محمد او احمد من السهل عليه ان
يلج ويقترض من البنوك باسعار اقل ترتفع
الاسعار لان الطلب يرتفع في السوق كثيرا
اعتقد ان المشهد ربما يصبح سهلا عندما
نقول ان محمد اقترض باقل كلفه
انفق باعلى مستوى دفع المنتج الى ان يرفع
الاسعار
ارتفع مستوى التضخم هنا الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي او البنوك المركزيه في الدول
تشعر بانه التضخم عندما يتجاوز المستويات
المسموح بها وهي في حدود اثنين الى ثلاثه
بالمئه
عندما تتجاوز ثلاثه بالمئه يصبح تضخم
متخول
هنا يعود الى ان يلتمس مسار اخر يسمى
بالتشديد النقد يحاول ان يمتص السيوله من
الاسواق بمعنى ان يمتص السيوله وقدره
الناس على الولوج الى الاقتراض فماذا يفعل
يرفع سعر الفائده فيعود محمد فيقول لماذا
اقترض الان واسعار الفائده مرتفعه
فاحجم انا وانت والمستثمر على الاقتراض
يعود الانفاق الى مستوياته المتدنيه
ينخفض الطلب ثم تنخفض الاسعار تباعا يعني
عندما تتحدث عن ذلك اتذكر بدايه في
الصحافه في عام 2008 كان في عز الازمه
الاقتصاديه العالميه كانت ازمه قروض
اضطررت حينها ان افهم فكره ان الناس
اقترضوا بفوائد قليله وفاقد قدرتهم على رد
هذه او دفع هذه القروض هل هل نحن في
سيناريو مشابه نوعا ما مشابه بالنسبه
للبنوك لانها اخذت اموال
من المودعين بسعر فائده اقل صفر فاصله
خمسه الى واحد بالمئه فتفاجئت بعد تغيير
السياسه النقديه انه اسعار فاذا ارتفعت
الى مستوى اربع فاصل 75% بعد ما لجا
الفدره الامريكي الى رفع اسعار الفائده
على ثمان مرات طب حينها في 2008 يعني كان
هناك الكثير من الاحاديث حول كيف يمكن ان
نتفادى الوقوع في نفس الركود الاقتصادي
والمساس بالاقتصاد العالمي من المسؤول عن
الازمه اليوم اذا كان يعني يبدو انه لم
يكن هناك دروس مستفاده هناك ثلاث مستويات
من المسؤوليه المسؤوليه الاولى تقع على
المشرع الذي لم يسن قوانين كافيه لحمايه
المنظومه المصرفيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كاخبار اقتصاد على المستوى
العالمي والمستوى الثاني هو الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي الذي يتقلب في سياساته النقديه
بين التشديد النقدي والتيسير النقدي بمعنى
بين خفض اسعار الفائده الى مستويات
المتدنيه لاتاحه الفرصه للمقترضين
للاقتراض بشكل اكبر ثم بعد ذلك يغير
سياسته الى رفع اسعار الفائده فيوقع
المقترضين من جهه في مشاكل
والمودعين من جهه اخرى في مشاكل وهذا ما
دفع بالمودعين بالنسبه لسيليكون الى ان
يسحب ودائعهم بسرعه لانه شعروا بان بنك
واد سيليكون بدا يبيع سنداته حتى
يستوفي متطلبات المودعين لانه بالنهايه هو
يحتاج الى اموال كي يعطيها لمحمد للمستثمر
للمودع الاول عندما بلغت مستويات طلبات
المذيعين مستويات اكبر فشله في ان يواكب
هذه الطلبات ربما كان في حدود سته الى
سبعه مليارات ثم تحولت الى سحوبات بحوالي
42 مليار دولار كيف لهذا البنك ان يستجيب
ل 42 مليار في ايام معدوده فدفع ذلك هذا
البنك الى ان يبيع سندات بخساره اثنين
مليار دولار هذا الامر اثر الرعب بالنسبه
للمودعين فعادوا سحب اموالهم من جديد
وبالتالي افلس بنك السيليكون لكن السلطات
كما قلت تدخلت
فدخت اموال ما تسمى بالقروض الطارئه
للبنوك في حدود 300 مليار دولار حتى
تتجاوز
انهيارات مشابهه للعام
2008 قلت انه من المسؤول قلنا المسؤول
الاول هي المشرع الذي سن قوانين لم تكن
كافيه لحمايه منظومه المصرفيه المسؤول
الثاني كان هو الاحتياطي الفطيره رفع فجاه
اسعار الفائده هو في ظنه انه يواجه التضخم
المتغور لكنه اثر ضمنيا على المقترض من
جهه وعن المودعين وعلى البنوك الصغار
والبنوك الصغيره والبنوك المتوسطه
المسؤوليه الثالثه كانت البنوك نفسها لانه
لم يكن لها القدره الكافيه على اداره
المخاطر وعلى اداره الديون البنوك ماذا
تفعل تستثمر القرود في اماكن اخرى لكي
تعود بالعائد بالنسبه اليها وبالنسبه
للمذيعين لكن اداره للمخاطر لم تكن
بالمستوى المطلوب اذا المسؤوليه كانت
ثلاثيه قوانين لم تكن كافيه لحمايه النظام
المصرفي الامريكي بشكل عام من في مثل
الازمات التي وقعت في 2008 الكل كان يقول
بانه بعد ازمه 2008 لن تتكر هذه الازمات
قيل هذا الامر في ازمه الركود والكساد
العالمي في عام
1929 تكررت الازمه ايضا في العام الفين مع
فقاعات الدوت كوم ثم تكررت في 2008 مع
ازمه الماليه والان تتكرر مع الازمه 2023
وفي تقدير ان الازمات لن تنتهي لان نظام
المصرفي العالمي يقوم على قاعده المتاجره
في الديون وليس في التنميه راس المال اذا
الدين
الدين يعلو على الدين والدين يعلو على
الدين والدين يعلو على الدين الى ان تصل
الى كون من الديون ويكفي ان نشير اننا حجم
الديون على مستوى العالمي تجاوز 300
تريليون دولار ثلاث مئه الف مليار دولار
300 الف مليار دولار وهو ما يعادل ثلاث
مرات حجم الاقتصاد العالمي بمعنى انه حجم
الديون على مستوى في العالم يتفوق على
الاقتصاد العالمي ككل بثلاث مرات اذا لن
يكون الاختصاد العالمي ككل كافيا في ان
يواجه حجم الديون الكبيره ولذلك انا دائما
اتوقع ان تقع الازمات ما دام حجم الديون
الكل على مستوى العالم يتفوق على الانتاج
والانتاج المحلي وعلى الاقتصاد العالمي
بشكل عام اذا مسؤوليه مشتركه كما قلت بين
البنوك التي تخاطر والتي لديها دائما رغبه
في المخاطره دون ان تكون لها اليات لاداره
هذه المخاطر واداره هذه الديون والمسؤوليه
الثاني هو للاحتياطي الفطره الامريكي او
البنوك المركزي الذي لابد ان تبحث على
اليه بديله لمساله تشديد الكمي والتيسير
الكمي بمعنى خفض اسعار الفائده ورفع اسعار
الفائده للسيطره على الاموال او السيوله
على المستوى الاسواق والمستوى الثالث كما
قلنا وهو
السن القوانين الكفيله بزجر
المتساهلين بجزر المفسدين
الرئيس الامريكي الحالي ووزيره الماليه
الحاليه وزيره الخزانه سيتم فتح تحقيق
منفصل مستقل لمعرفه من المتسبب في هذه
الازمه خلال هذا الامر في العام 2008
كانت ضحيه ودافع الضرائب لانه الاحتياطي
الامريكي يدفع لهذه البنوك التي تسببت في
الازمه تسببت في الازمه فانقذها على حساب
دافع الضرائب لماذا لانه من واجب ان يؤخذ
هذه البنوك لان تشكل العصا السحريه
والمحرك الاساسي في الاقتصاد العالمي ككل
يكفي ان نشير الى ان اجمالي اصول البنوك
الامريكيه التي تقدر باكثر من 4000 وست
مئه بنك
اجمالي الاصول
يقدر باثنين وعشرين تريليون دولار
22 تريليون دولار اصول البنوك الامريكيه
وهو يوازي حجم الاقتصاد الامريكي من جهه
وخمس مرات الحجم اقتصاد الالماني وست مرات
حجم الاقتصاد الفرنسي
واكثر اثنا عشر مره اجمال الاقتصاد العربي
ككل هذه الارقام تدلل على ان
البنوك في منظومه الاقتصاد العالمي هي
المتحكم الاساسي اوامر كبيره ربما تتسبب
في الازمات فتسقط منافسين وتلتهم اسماك
صغيره ثم نعود مره اخرى الى دائره من
الازمات تبدا بالازدهار ثم ازدهار اقوى ثم
ركود ثم ازمات ثم نعود مره اخرى الى
ازدهار وتكون دائما البنوكيه المستفيد
الاكبر خاصه البنوك الكبيره جدا يعني مزيج
من سوء الاداره مع الخلل البنيوي مع
الفساد كلها مجتمعه الاوامل تعطينا
بالنهايه ازمات تتراكم واعتقد انه الفتره
المقبله ربما ستكون هناك تناسل لمزيد من
الازمات ليست رؤيه متشائمه ولكن لان بنيه
الاقتصاد العالمي قائمه على تدوير الديون
صناعه الديون على تجاره الديون وليس على
تنميه راس المال بالاساس يعني هذه عمليات
الضخ التي جرت في اقل من 24 ساعه الاموال
لانقاذ بعض البنوك برايك
مجرد مرحليه ولن ولم تنهي الازمه اعتقد ان
الازمه انتهت مرحليا بالفعل الفتره
الامريكي والسلطات الامريكيه ضخت اموال
كبيره جدا في
البنوك وخاصه البنك
الثالثين مليار دولار واضطرت عدد من
البنوك ان تنقذ هذا البنك لانه اذا انهار
هذا البنك الرابع
انه الكروت ستسقط تباعا والبنوك ستدخل في
ازمات مستمره خسر البنوك الامريكيه من
الاقتصاد الامريكي هو الاعظم على مستوى
العالم اذا تدخلت السلطات الامريكيه تدخل
احتياطي الفطار كما قلنا من باب الاقراض
الطارئ بثلاث مئه مليار دولار وايضا على
مستوى العالمي تم انقاذ
حيث تدخل السلطات السويسريه بضخي في
المرحله الاولى 54 مليار دولار ثم ما يسمى
بمرحله الاستحواذ حيث استحوذ اليوبي اس
البنك المنافس على هذا البنك ومن ثم
اوقفنا مرحليا الازمه في سويسرا مرحليا في
المانيا ومرحليا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لكن مسببات الازمه او الازمات
ما تزال قائمه كما قلت تجاره الديون ورغبه
جامحه لدى البنوك للمخاطره اكثر دون ان
تكون لها اساسات لاداره المخاطر بشكل
المطلوب وايضا غياب كما قلنا قوانين زاجره
قويه يمكن ان توقف البنوك والاساس في كل
هذا هو تضارب المصالح ما بين مصالح خاصه
للبنوك الكبيره والمؤسسات وما بين المشرع
البنوك الكبيره والمؤسسات والشركات ترغب
في ان تكون هناك سوق حره لا يتدخل فيها
احد توجد فيها يد خفيه ما
خفيه ليش تتدخل فتعدل مستويات السوق من
ازمه الى انتعاش الى ركود وهكذا بينما
السلطات تسعى الى ان تسن قوانين للحفاظ
على المنافسه النزيهه للسيطره على الاسواق
من الناحيه الماليه من الناحيه الاقتصاديه
في المقابل في المؤسسه ان تكون هناك اسواق
حره اذا نحن بصدد اقتصاد ليبرالي بين
قوسين متوحش توجد فيه اوامر تاكل الاسماك
الصغيره
والمتفرج يكون والضحيه دائما يكون المقترض
او المودع المستهلك او المواطن وليس
المستثمر الصغير وانما
الكبار هم الذين يسيطرون بالنهايه هناك
لاعبون كبار في المشهد عندما ينتعش لاعبون
اخرين من الاحتياط يهددون هذه هؤلاء
اللاعبون نعيد الكره من جديد حتى صرت
مقتنع بانه ازمه العام 2008 كانت مدبره
امام الناس الذي يؤمنون بانه هذه الازمه
كانت مدبره لانه الاقتصاد الصيني كان ينمو
بسرعه كبيره جدا بمعدلات تفوق العشره
بالمئه
وكان يمكن الاقتصاد الصيني ان يلحق
بالاقتصاد الامريكي او يتفوق على اقتصاد
الامريكي في عام 2025 واذا تاخر سيكون في
العام 2030 لانه معدل نمو اقتصاد الصيني
كان بحدود 10 الى 11% بينما معدل اختصار
الامريكي
هنا كنا بحاجه الى تعديل اوراق الكروت من
جديد خلق ازمه
حتى يدخل العالم في ازمات والذي خلق
الازمه يملك مفتاح هذه الازمه يرمي مفتاح
هذه الازمه في البحر حتى يسبح الكل في هذه
الازمه وانا الذي اعرف مفاتيح المداخل هذه
الازمه افتحه الازمه فابدا من جديد في
الصعود ولذلك راينا كيف ان الاقتصاد
الامريكي الذي كان متسببا في الازمه
العالميه هو الذي خرج من الازمه العالميه
مبكره هل اذا اذا يعني بناء على هذه
النظريه هل يمكن ان يكون من اشهده اليوم
سيناريو مماثل هل يمكن ان نشهد انهيارات
في دول اخرى ما عدا يعني بعد المانيا
وسويسرا
يمكن ان نقول مرحليا تمت السيطره على
الازمه المرحله لانه
الازمه لم تلحق البنوك عفوا البنوك الكبير
ربما لحقت ببنك سيليكون وهو ترتيب تقريبا
حول 16 باقي البنوك الاخرى هي بنوك صغيره
البنوك الامريكيه وليس البنوك خارج امريكا
ضخمه كما بحدود 22 تريليون دولار اجمالي
4000 بنك لكن بالنهايه اصول هذه البنوك
تتراوح ما بين تقريبا اربعين الى الخمسين
مليار دولار اذا هي اصغر الامريكي قد يكون
اكبر بنك في المنطقه العربيه في عدد من
المناطق الاخرى قلت مرحليا يمكن ان نقول
ان الازمه قد توقفت وليس انتهت لكن
المسببات ما تزال قائمه وذلك نحن نحتاج
الى منظومه مصرفيه قويه الى سن قوانين
قويه وهذا الامر لن يتاتى على الاقل في
الاقتصاد الامريكي مادام القطاع الخاص هو
المتحكم في العمليه وفي المشهد ككل قد
يكون امر اسلم في اوروبا عندما تدخلت
سلطات السويسريه بسرعه لكي تنهي ازمه
كريدي سويس واحد من اكبر المصاريف على
المستوى العالم ولو كان قد انهار يمكن ان
ينهار الاقتصاد السويسري ومعه عدد من
الاقتصاديات لماذا لان الاقتصاد لان عفوا
البنك السويسري
[موسيقى]
وصلنا لعالم العربي يعتقد اننا لن نتاثر
ولكن في عام 2008 نحن فعلا تاثرنا كثيرا
هناك شركات افلست هناك اشخاص
طردوا من الاف كان هناك تسريحات بالالاف
لموظفين في المنطقه هذه الازمه اليوم كيف
ستتاثر بها الدول العربيه والبنوك الخليج
البنوك العربيه والخليجيه وليس حتى
الاقتصادات عندنا ثلاث مستويات التاثر
السريع وهو البورصات لان البورصات تنكشف
على ما يقع في المستوى العالم عندما ينزل
تنزل مؤشرات في البورصات الامريكيه وفي
البورصات الاوروبيه
بشكل اوتوماتيكي تنزل
الاسهم في البورصات العربيه اذا التاثر
الاول كان البورصات العربيه وبشكل اقل في
البورصات الخارجيه لان اقتصاديه تتوفر على
ملعقه ماليه كبيره جدا لانها مصدره رقم
واحد للنفط على مستوى العالم اسعار النفط
الله تعالى على مستوى العالم مرتفعين
المستويات كبيره جدا ما وفر الاقتصاديات
الخليجيه سيوله ماليه جنب الى حد ما ازمات
كبيره المستوى الثاني وهو الاستثمارات
التي تضعها الدول العربيه في هذه البنوك
اذا لدينا استثمارات عربيه فكري دي سويس
اذا تاثرت لدينا استثمارات في السندات
الامريكيه لاستثمارات في بنوك امريكيه اذا
هذا التاثر ايضا في المستوى الثاني
المستوى استثمارات في اماكن ربما تكون ذات
مخاطر عاليه جدا عندما ترتفع مستوى
المخاطر في تلك الدول تتاثر استثمارات
العربيه بشكل طبيعي جدا المستوى الثالث من
التاثر هو ارتفاع اسعار الدولار وارتفاع
اسعار الذهب لماذا في الازمات
يجنح الناس الى ما تسمى بالملادات الامنه
الدولار هو عمله رئيسيه على مستوى العالم
اذا هو صمام امان بالنسبه للمستثمرين
يستثمرون في الدولار يشترون الدولار يرتفع
الطلب على الدولار
يرتفع سعر الدولار في مقابل العملات
الاخرى تنهار العملات الاخرى او على الاقل
تنخفض العملات ومن العملات العربيه التي
ليست لها اساسات قويه جدا اذا المستوى
الثالث من التاثر هو ارتفاع اسعار الدولار
وارتفاع اسعار الذهب في مقابل انخفاض
العملات الاخرى انخفاض العملات العربيه
اثر بشكل طبيعي على ارتفاع مستويات
الاسعار في الداخل لماذا لان الدول
العربيه لا تنتج الغداء
وخدماتها بشكل كبير جدا اذا اغلب الغداء
الدول العربيه هو غذاء مستورد اذا نستورد
الغداء فنستورد معه الاسعار المرتفعه
فنستورد ما يسمى بالتضخم المستورد ترتفع
مستويات التضخم ترتفع الاسعار يتاثر
المستهلك اذا ما يقع في الولايات المتحده
الكماليه الامريكيه حتى قيل بانه اذا عطست
امريكا يشعر العالم كله به مرض الزكام اذا
حصلت الازمه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يتاثر العالم ككل والحلقه دائما
المستهلكين ارتفاع
مستوى الدولار يؤثر ضمنيا على الدول التي
ليست لها احتياطات من الدولار بالشكل
المطلوب التي تعطيها امكانيه للولوج الى
الاسواق العالميه والاستيراد بشكل اكبر
وهذا يتزامن طبعا مع ازمه ازمه سلاسل
التوريد التي ما تزال مستمره حتى الان لان
هذا من من ضحايا ازمه كورونا عندما تم
اقفال الاقتصاد العالمي ككل كانت لدينا
سلاسل امراه ازمه سلاسل التوريد على مستوى
العالم وهذا اثر على انسيابيه السلع
والخدمات نحو الاسواق خاصه الاسواق
العالميه اذا تاثر كبير لكن اعتقد انه
بوجود حلول للازمه الحاليه قد تتلاشى
ضمنيا الازمات داخل الوطن العربي وان كان
الوطن العربي له ما يكفيه من الازمات
الضخمه يعني لا نحتاج لاستيراد التضخم
جميله مصطلحاتكم شاعريه نشعر التضخم
المستورد وكانه يمكننا ان نوقف التضخم فقط
باقفال الباب وربما هذا يعني ما بتتسعى
اليه بعض الدول مع تنام التداول بالعملات
المحليه مع اللجوء لبدائل هل بدا فقدان
الثقه بالنظام العالمي الامريكي مثلا خلال
المئه سنه الماضيه الى الان تناسلت عندنا
ازمات كثيره جدا كثيره منها لكن الاضخم
منها الكساد 1929 والازمه الماليه في
العام 2008 وازمه السيود عفوا
ما تزال الى الان يعني نجترو ديولها الى
الان والان ازمه يعني تمويل او ما يسمى
بالسيوله الان في الازمه الحاليه اذا
ستتناسب بكل تاكيد ازمات اخرى الشعار في
هذه المرحله وازمه الثقه لدى المودعين لدى
المقترضين وفي مستوى اعلى لدى الدول ايضا
التي تراهن على الاقتصاد الراسمالي
المتوحش فتجد نفسها في خدم الازمات هنا ن
عدد من الدول ذات الاقتصاديات القويه تبحث
عن بديل الصين يبحث عن بديل دول تبحث عن
بديل منظمه شانغهاي تبحث عن بديل حتى لا
تظل تحت رحمه سلطه الاقتصاد الامريكي طبعا
للتعامل بالعملات المحليه حصل هذا بين
روسيا والصين بين روسيا وتركيا بين العراق
والصين تعاملات بين بالعملات المحليه
لربما تقليل وساطه الدولار لانه تعرفين ما
نوع المستوى العالمي عندما استورد من
المغرب استورد من المغرب او المغرب يستورد
من اوروبا بانه الدولار يكون دائما حاضرا
كوسيط الى جانب العملات الاخرى اليورو
وجونيسترليني واليان الياباني وهكذا لكن
بالنهايه سلطه الدولار ما تزال قائمه وهي
الاقوى وتستمد هذه القوه من ثلاث عناصر
اساسيه القوه السياسيه للولايات المتحده
الامري القوه العسكريه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه القواعد العسكريه في كل العالم
الدولار محمي بهذه المستوى الثلاث قوه
سياسيه قوه عسكريه وقوه اقتصاديه اقتصاد
الامريكي في حدود 23 التريليون دولار
واقرب منافس له هو اقتصاد الصيني باربعه
عشر مليار دولار مع فارق كبير جدا
الامريكيه 280 الى 300 مليون نسمه بينما
في الصين اكثر من مليار نسمه اذا هناك
فارق كبير جدا اقرب المنافسين دولار او
الاوروبي الدولار مهيمن في المعاملات
الماليه العالميه اغلب الاحتياطات لدى
البنوك حتى الصين نفسها حتى اوروبا 60 الى
نحو 65% احتياطات من الدولار
احتياطات التعاملات التجاريه تقوم على
الدولار حتى يقال انه من بين ثلاث بضائع
من بين اربعه بضائع المستوى العالم يا اما
مضى امريكيه يا اما يا اما مدخلات المنتج
فيها امريكيه يا اما تتداول بالدولار
الامريكي اذا هو مسيطر بشكل كبير جدا وحتى
يعني الملاحق له وهو اليورو لا يشكل
تقريبا ما بين 18 الى 20 بالمئه وباقي
العملات الاخرى اذا دولار مسيطر محمي بقوه
سياسيه قوه عسكريه لكن مثل هذه التحركات
تعطي اشاره على الاقل بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بان العالم ربما اصبح
غير راغب في نظام اقتصادي يقوم على
الهيمنه الامريكيه وعلى هيمنه الدولار اذا
هناك بحث عن بدائل بدات التحركات
دعنا نعيد ان نبسط للمستمع يعني مثلا روعه
تريد ان تقترض من محمد لماذا يدخل الدولار
الامريكي وسيط لماذا لا نتبادل فقط بفرق
العملات بيننا يعني اذا اردنا ان نشرحها
على صعيد الدول مثلا المغرب واليورو
الاتحاد الاوروبي لماذا يدخل الدولار
كوسيط وعندما يدخل كوصيد كيف يستفيد
الدولار الامريكي الدولار الامريكي او
العملات الاخرى طيب لنقول ان
دول اكثر تعاملا بالدولار منها المغرب
مثلا يتعامل باليورو بمستوى اول والدولار
بمستوى ثاني دعنا ناخذ دول الشرق الاوسط
دول الخليج ومصر كل مستورداتها من الخارج
تقوم بالدولار كيف تستورد هذه الدوله لابد
ان تكون لها احتياطات لانه الاستيراد من
الخارج لا يكون من العملات المحليه العمله
المحليه حدود تعاملها هو محلي عندما يذهب
محمد او او اروى او اي احد للسوق يتعامل
بالدرهم المغربي او بالدينار التونسي او
غيره من العملات الاخرى حتى بيتنا في
تجربه لبنان نتعامل حتى بالدولار في
التعاملات المحليه مع
مثلا العمله السودانيه او العمله لبنان او
لبنان يختلف سعر الصرف عن ملايين ملايين
يعني وصل الان السعر تقريبا في السوق
السوداء ما بين 90 الى مئه الى 110 الف
ليره في مقابل دولار واحد بمعنى تحتاج الى
شاحنه لحمل الليرات اللبنانيه حتى تشتري
قطعه قماش من وهذا مشكل كبير جدا اذا هناك
عملات ضعيفه جدا في مقابل عملات دولار قوي
جدا بالمناسبه الدولار الامريكي لا يلتمس
قوته فقط كما قلنا من عناصر ثلاث هذه
وانما ايضا في رغبه المتعاملين في الاسواق
في امتلاك الدولار باعتباره الملاذ الامن
في لحظه الازمات لو سالتني انا محمد او
سالت اروى او اي احد من العمله تفضل سيقول
لك الدولار احتاج الى الدولار لانها على
الاقل تجنبني تقلبات اسعار الفائده تقلبات
التضخم لان عندما املك الدولار على الاقل
اتجاوز بها الازمات التي تحصل في ارتفاع
الاسعار
عندما نتحدث عن ارتفاع بصل في المغرب الى
2 دولار او في تونس الى ثلاثه دولار
نتحدث بالدولار وليس بالعمله المحليه تقوم
يكون دائما بالدولار اذا الدولار يظل وسيط
جدا حتى الصين التي ترفع يدها في الصباح
وتدعو الله ان تسقط امريكا حتى تاخذ الصين
مكانه هي نفسها تعود في المساء تدعو الله
حتى تظل امريكا قائمه لان الصين تملك ماء
ما يقدر باتنين تريليون دولار ديون سندات
امريكيه اذا انخفاض الدولار او انهيار
الدولار يعني انخفاض ما يوجد من احتياط
هذا البنوك المركزيه وخاصه الصين اذن نحن
نظل دائما تحت
رحمتي هيمنه الدولار الامريكي ربما
فرستقبل نحتاج الى شيء اخر طب بعد ازمات
البنوك العالميه وبدا التداول بالعملات
المحليه بين بعض الدول هل بات اليوم هناك
بديل مثلا اقوى لسعر الفائده مثلا التمويل
الاسلامي درنا نقول ان العالم بحاجه الى
نظام اقتصادي جديد
جديد يتجاوز الاحاديه الامريكيه وهيمنه
الدولار ولكن كيف بدات بعض المراحل كما
قلنا التعامل بالعملات المحليه بدات
تحركات وتكتلات البرازيل الان الرئيس
الاولى موجود في الصين للبحث على اقوى
تعاملات اقتصاديه اقوى وهذا الامر يعطي
اشاره كما قلت
انه هناك فقدان ثقه في النموذج الاقتصادي
الحالي فقدان ثقه في النموذج المصرفي
الامريكي فقدان ثقه في النموذج المصرفي
العالمي وهناك حاجه الى البحث عن نظام
اقتصادي علمي ما هو هذا النظام هنا السؤال
نحتاج الى قرارات دوليه جريئه نعم التمويل
الاسلامي يعطي بديل من الناحيه النظريه
لانه يقوم على تنميه راس المال وليس على
صناعه الديون لنعرف ان التمويل الاسلامي
لا يقوم على النقد يخلق النقد وانما النقد
يدخل السوق فيخلق سلعه او خدمه ثم يعطي
نقل ثم يعود الى البنك البنك الاسلامي او
البنوك الاسلاميه تقوم على خلق
الاقتصاد حقيقي خلق خدمات حقيقيه وخلق سلع
حقيقيه بينما الاقتصاد التقليدي يقوم على
اقراض الاقراض واقراض الاموال الاموال
تخلق الاموال الاموال تخلق اموال بينما
الاقتصاد الاسلامي يقوم على المال يخلق
البضاعه ويخلق السلعه والسلعه تخلق ربح
والربح يخلق اموال وهكذا تدور اذا صحيح قد
يكون التمويل الاسلامي بديل لكن حدود
انتشاره الان في حدود واحد بالمئه اذا
اجمالي اصول البنوك الاسلامي على مستوى
العالم لا تشكل سوى واحد بالمئه اذا تسعه
وتسعين بالمئه الاقتصاد التقليدي او
البنوك التقليديه في مقابل واحد بالمئه
بالنسبه للبنوك الاسلاميه ان كنا نرغب ان
يكون التمويل التشارك بين قوسين يعني
نعطيه يافطه اسلامي وانما بنوك تشاركيه
بمعنى ان يتشارك البنك مع المستثمر في
الربح والخساره وليس في الربح فقط
الخساره على المقترض والمودع والربح على
البنك كما هو في الاقتصاد التقليدي في
القصاد التشاركي الربح والخساره على مين
على البنك وعلى المستثمر وعلى المفترض
بمعنى اذا ربح البنك يربح الجميع واذا خسر
البنك يخسر الجميع وهذا الاقتصاد حقيقي
لكن هذا الامر يحتاج الى ان نسعفه بقرارات
دوليه بمعنى في العام 1944 كان هما يسمي
مؤتمر بروتين وود من خلاله تم تاسيس صندوق
النقد الدولي والبنك الدولي ومنظمه
التجاره العالميه واصبح فيها الدولار
مسيطرا حتى اصبح مناكفا او معاييرا للذهب
حتى بيتنا نسمع ما يسمى بكذبه الدولار مع
نيكسون سيطره الدولار بهذه الطريق اذا
نحتاج الى مؤتمر دولي على غرار مؤتمر 1944
لكي يؤسس لمؤسسات بديله صندوق النقد
الدولي وبديل البنك الدولي وفضيله لمنظمه
التجاره العالمي العالميه وبدل هذه
المنظومه حتى نحصل على نظام اقتصادي عالمي
هذا الامر قرارات السياسيه دوليه
وعمر مديد وزمن طويل هذه ليست نظره
تشاؤميه ولكن هل هيهات ان خدعنا نقول كيف
لاوروبا ان تتوحد مع اسيا وانت توحد مع
افريقيا تتوحد مع امريكا اللاتينيه حتى
نسقط الدولار في تقدير سقوط الدولار
وانهياره معنى سقوط الاقتصاد العالمي ككل
يمكن ان يسقط الدولار في لحظه من اللحظات
الان بتمنى نتحدث عن ان هي نعم تماما لا
اعتقد احدا انت قلت الصين لا تريده ان
يسقط بالضبط الكل
قرش الكل يرغب بان يسقط هذا الاقتصاد بهذه
المنظومه
لان ذلك سينعكس على مستثمرين الصغار على
المواطن على المستهلك وايضا نحن لا
من دعاه النظام الاشتراكي انه الكل يربح
بنفس المستوى لا ولكن كل
وان لا يدفع الثمن الاخرين ايضا لا تاكلوا
الكل الان الميزان الموجود على مستوى
العالم ثمانين مقابل عشرين
ثمانين من المنظومه الاقتصاديه من منظومه
البشر من منظومه المستهلكين يستفيدون من
20% من الاقتصاد وعشرين بالمئه من
الهوامير يملكون ثمانين بالمئه من
الاقتصاد يكفي انه يشيل لنا 400
سريع على مستوى العالم يملكون التريليونات
الدولارات على مستوى العالم الان
المواطنين في لبنان في السودان في المغرب
هم فقراء الى مستوى التضخم عندما تذهب الى
السوق الان ومعك دولارين لا تستطيع من قبل
كنت تستطيع ان تاخذ اثنين كيلو طماطم مع
كيلو بطاطا مع كيلو بصل الان اثنين دولار
في المغرب في تونس عدد من دول لا يمكن
[موسيقى]